welcome to this video against the drew
yeah I I already once failed to
pronounce that in any any kind of decent
manner to risk to get an or something
it's from some other language okay let's
see I'm going with B three-year the
ideas that some setups like this yeah I
can take that I can take the the night
now I'm going to do it it's an
interesting interesting way to play just
doubling doubling the pawns okay now
cabinets and check the center currently
deform I maybe you can play it d 494
bishan be five no he decides to capture
surprising Wow ever heard of development
seems to be unpopular nowadays f4 Wow
can really afford that okay I can go see
51 idea and then take on a form queen
bee three is also an interesting maybe
queen bee three and prevent short
castles and okay if you take you three
well I don't mind ok let's go to form
head looks very awkward for black yeah i
was thinking about it and I'm not sure
what I should do now just c5 and it's
good or do I have something something
better even okay is in the in the fork
is still in that fork maybe here seems a
bit lame to trade queens
I'm also threatening to take on f4 now
after Bishop takes a for Queenie for
would win that Bishop so in some cases I
will just take it whatever
is that one of them maybe I don't see
anything wrong with taking their pawn at
the moment
yeah nothing wrong with it King f7 can
probably never going to guess one of his
moves sometimes you have those kind of
games where you're sitting then you
never understand or guess or in any way
can predict what the other guys doing
it's probably one of them okay keep the
pawn threatening c5 now
45 edits don't don't tell me that that
isn't totally devastating then
something's wrong here a4 a5 g5
and the best best thing is that the
queen is on a six of all places totally
not contributing so let's see I can
flick an e6 check why can what can I
have met many things push-up shakes
taking it with the Queen taking with the
queen is also very strong it's really
it's a spoiled for choice iam okay
that's not people it's really really
very silly to lose to some kind of pre
move prima facie a chance game okay so
how do we win here it looks like it
should be some chick made Queen e72 f5
takes them ok that's a mate do I have
some other no let's let's do that made
check and not look for quicker one check
black resins guy was a weird game okay
d5 expected I'm okay with that and six
castles ok now this moon yeah I don't
know really want to take on c4 on it and
then go F form but it's that's very
taking liberties right i mean just
totally no development no center nothing
how to believe okay that's just one of
the moves that that make sense 97 okay
i'm going to you for any way here yeah i
mean here c5 is already really strong I
just wasn't sure if if this is um yeah
if this is enough or if this is too soft
you know I mean I get 93 possibly d5 and
it is excellent i canna compass on one
point something 1.2 awesome but it's not
a bad bad move as well bad move Edom GF
4 still they played that move after
which i'm grabbing the pawn and then the
King f7 okay I'm just keeping this
keeping this and yeah I thought this
move
okay i can i can cover it and I mean I
have that pawn and and the center and
everything's nice but I mean after that
I think it's just such as probably over
c5 is a big threat now here I am okay I
was thinking this but i have d 5 that's
important this is check is a neat little
idea so c5 and now he for this is just
yeah this is the end yeah it was it was
a bit too to lose what black did here in
that game thanks for watching